[Applause]
all right a warm welcome for for our
friend Fox Business host Larry Kudlow is
here
there was a point in my life when I
lived paycheck to paycheck a lot of
years of my early adult life it's not
fun that's now two-thirds of the country
now we have bad economic news and every
smart Economist that I read or or hear
they're all saying the same thing we're
going into a recession do you agree
agree yeah I do we look at we um we're
in a stagflation right now so you have
one percent you have to help people
explain that I'm gonna I'm going there
so you have
you never trust me you never trust me
I've been I've only been doing this
about 45 50 years why don't you just
take the knife in and twist it harder
Larry go ahead
we're running a little less than one
percent growth all right and the
inflation rate is about six percent this
is the last five quarters so starting
with Biden's First full year in office
which was 2022 last year right all right
that's four quarters and this first
quarter
0.9 percent real growth and six percent
inflation so that's when the inflation
rate is above the growth rate that's
called stag inflation it was a term
started in the 1970s when I was a junior
Economist on Wall Street and the Federal
Reserve and then worked for Ronald
Reagan what it means is in plain English
is that inflation is rising faster than
incomes inflation is rising faster than
wages so real wages
living standards have been falling now
for almost three years under Joe Biden
and I'll just give you a quick rundown
prices okay it's all about prices
um
all items 15 Consumer Price Index 15
increase
groceries food at home almost 20 percent
energy
39 31 percent
gasoline and going 36 and a half percent
now
energy gasoline
electricity
food at home that is what you use and
that's why people are living paycheck to
paycheck the price increases are
outstripping the wages people are
working they have jobs the trouble is
they're not making any money when they
come home the way this should work is
the inflation rate should be like one or
two percent and then your wages are
going to be five or six percent and
you'd be in great shape which by the way
is what I want to make one more Point
let me get in one question sorry because
Joe inherited 1.4 inflation rate that's
correct that's the point I was going to
make so the American people okay so the
I helped you
um oh so always so the American people
that are suffering they really need help
and answers how do you advise people
that are living paycheck to paycheck or
cashing in their pensions or putting you
know things on their credit card you
know Bare Necessities well look at um
Joe Biden is a
cannot tell the truth about the economy
so he keeps saying he inherited
a terrible economy with high inflation
and those are flat out lies so if you go
back to the beginning of 2021 when Biden
was inaugurated okay
Trump left him a six and a half percent
growth rate and a 1.4 percent inflation
rate because of our tax cuts and our
deregulation and we had a strong dollar
I was privileged and honored to be his
National Economic Council director
that's what we left by in a year in a
year Biden runs this thing down to less
than one percent growth with six percent
inflation and as I say grocery prices
running at 19 and a half percent you
know you got to do the best you can here
I don't want to see you sell all your
assets don't do that you know why
better times are coming adults are going
to come back in this game we will
all right I gotta go I'm up for the
clock but we we will the answer is we
will we will over listen to me trust me
I'm an old guy I've been around for a
long time we will the voters of this
country will overthrow Biden's socialism
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else